se cumplen 10 días desde el estallido de
las protestas masivas en kazajistán y el
silencio va recuperando las calles de
almaty donde activistas familiares y
amigos denuncian el secretismo de estado
y la incomunicación con los detenidos
tabla joyas germanies hay un centro de
detención aquí el departamento de
interior es bastante grande y aquí
retienen a los detenidos y abogados y
mis familiares nadie puede acceder los
abogados deberían estar presentes
durante los interrogatorios pero como
ves nadie puede entrar en las puertas
bloquean el paso a los abogados y los
familiares ni siquiera tenemos la lista
de detenidos lo que sí se conoce es la
cifra de detenidos según las autoridades
se acerca a las doce mil personas
hicimos una protesta pacífica el 4 de
enero mi amigo incluso le pudo llamar
hermanos santos equipo bitch fue
detenido ese día 4 primero lo retuvieron
en la oficina distrital del interior y
luego nos dijeron que estaba aquí en el
departamento del interior pero estamos
aquí desde el 6 de enero y no sabemos si
está vivo o muerto y están jodidos
el gobierno kazajo ha abierto cerca de
300 investigaciones penales por
disturbios y agresiones a la fuerza
pública mientras que naciones unidas
pide que se investiguen las
circunstancias de la muerte de más de
160 manifestantes y que los detenidos
tengan acceso a un juicio justo
bajo el derecho internacional la gente
tiene derecho a protestar pacíficamente
y expresar sus opiniones
todos los detenidos por ejercer estos
derechos deben ser liberados
inmediatamente
al mismo tiempo tenemos que dejar claro
que también vimos personas armadas
tomando las calles en almaty y en otras
partes de kazajistán taking the suites
conmocionado por hans están con la
protesta sofocada la organización del
tratado de seguridad colectiva alianza
militar liderada por rusia anunció la
retirada de las tropas del territorio
kazajo a partir de este jueves